on va jouer au jeu plus est court plus
c'est bon pour cette manche va devoir
deviner si morceaux à vous de buzz et le
plus vite possible falloir vite vous
inquiète
mais attention à chaque nouvel ace l'ex
à chaque nouvel extrait se raccourcir à
d'accord d'accord je ne soutiens pas
compris au début j'ai pour lui au début
c'est alex les 2 6 secondes puis après
c'est un excédent se retrouvent pas
question répondent à l'autre gagne deux
points et enfin il faut qu'on réponde
pas alors bah oui c'est vrai oui
alors attachez vous avantager vous me
donnez les deux les deux interprètes et
le titre de laquelle les deux
interprètes puisque c'est des duos et le
titre delachaux attention partie 6
secondes pour retrouver ça
alors c'est ici c'est maître gims avait
foule et mita mais là il faut donner
tout mais le type banane la ceni fait
pour nous alors le maître gims évitant
non non et le trail au point mort
les faits comme moi oui mais oui pardon
voyez votre mère je voulais mais j'ai un
peu mal aux pieds dantas on vous voit
pas on voit pas vos pieds mais quand
vous vous lèverez vous remercier du bien
entendu on va l'avoir c'est très très
bon attention donc pas bon ouais 5
secondes
les excuses moi rockstar tu veux écouter
de la musique à le micro de qui non mais
c'est c'est un micro qui traînait là
d'accord c'est un micro qui traînait
animé fait ta victoire
attention 5 secondes pour retrouver sa
fille
mutations besoin de rien envie de toi
moi
oh
vers la fin
ça
c'est ça
le temps
oui
merci donc un point ici on est à dix
points par toujours attention 4 secondes
pour retrouver sa du château c'est ici à
mama shelter 6-0 face à la mer se retire
donc pas déchirer ce tabou d'armes qui
n'a que deux sanglots
g
de fait le crochet lewis a rien à dire
tu t'appuies on la baisse n'est sûr et
je peux vous proposer d'enlever un
maillon faible de votre équipe à chacun
dans un instant pour la dernière pour
vous dit non on reste tous ensemble des
tarés dans d'autres nous non non on va
enlever quelqu'un tant que chef d'équipé
pour d'enlever quelqu'un puis pourquoi
tel que proclamé chef des leaders et on
proclame à tchô trois secondes ont
retrouvé sa fille de céline dion le gard
où sous le vent
c'est parti
mais la musique c'est pas le bon c'est
bon c'est sympa
nada passé ce matin alors est ce que
vous l'avez sous le banc non non ça doit
être ça
ça
jet privé
le roi
attention les chérubins
attention si vous avez deux secondes
pour retrouver chercher ça ici il s'agit
de masques à lobito et natasha st-pier
trouvera tu trouve très beau
plus qu'il n'en faut
en finale
le match
je fais ça
pourquoi le
castaldi s'appelle bo a remporté à l ai
dit quoi
minés mais tout ça
j'avais battu lorient dont sera jamais
moi je vous aurais dit est-ce que tu es
juste
cela dit du coup ben vous pouvez
peut-être répondre merci jamais pendant
le service
régions vda envoyé s'appelle maurice
bassabi chez pika pika aller alors ce
prime et à montrer dans les écoles de
tête on est malade alors attention à
avoir une seconde pour trouver le
dernier sur ce que tu m'entends et aux
tragédies tragédie ici à l'autre qui dit
n'importe quoi pendant le live tragédie
et au non
oh
l'état veut voir qu'il va ta kelly on me
demande de fait attention
faites attention qui dit à quoi niveau
des jambes fatah dans son but le dis à
mes jambes oui oui oui il faut le couper
la tête alors voilà on dit ça pour vous
dire merci
les chérit le point va donc à richie va
faire un point bas vers un point sur les
poires maladroit
hélas non